so this week as promised
Republicans who now control the house
set up a new committee modeled after the
famous Frank Church Committee of the 70s
to investigate the FBI and the Intel
agencies which are playing what appear
to be decisive roles in American
politics now that's an offense against
democracy you can have a democracy in
which government agencies secretly work
to control the outcome that's tyranny of
course no decent person should want that
but Republicans rather than Democrats
rather rather than welcoming the
scrutiny and the transparency the
sunlight
are responding with panic watch this
today we have the first of their many
demands on display an open-ended
investigation into whatever conspiracy
theories may be headlining the
right-wing Echo chamber at the moment Mr
Speaker rise in strong opposition to H
Rez 12th the Insurrection protection
committee this is all about deep State
nonsense let's call it what it really is
the Republican committee to obstruct
Justice Russia is one of our most
dangerous adversaries we're in the
middle of a national security Quagmire
and to undermine that through
investigations of the FBI and Central
Intelligence is going to be extremely
dangerous the Maga extremist Fringe of
the Republican party will use this
committee to push Q Anon conspiracy
theories and lies from True social
they're going to use it to Gin up fake
investigations into non-existent
scandals I think we need to just start
calling this the tinfoil hack committee
oh so there's verification right there
if you're wondering if the federal
agencies FBI CIA and a bunch of others
are actually being used as tools of the
democratic party to change political
outcomes now we know for sure because if
you're a government official and you are
panicked at the idea that what you are
doing will become public you're doing
something wrong by definition
and it's not just the Intel agencies
whose Behavior they want to keep secret
Democrats in Congress also don't want
you to have any idea where the hundred
billion dollars went that we've sent to
Ukraine
so we spent 100 billion dollars to
Ukraine and then candy rice
who's still talking about foreign policy
and public amazingly announces this
weekend that Ukraine is losing okay so
where'd all the money go well you can't
know that what's his lenski and his wife
what they do with it
this weekend Joe Biden announced we're
going to send still more billions to
Ukraine this month
today we jointly announced you've
already gotten copies of it a statement
saying that we're going to increase the
support for Ukraine we are going to
provide the Bradley infantry fighting
Vehicles the United States to the
ukrainians and the Germans are going to
provide the Martyr infantry fighting
vehicles that they have to ukrainians in
addition we're going to help defend
Ukraine against Russian air attacks
Germany's also announced that today
that's going to provide the ukrainians
a uh the to deal with the air attacks a
patriot air defense system we're gonna
we're gonna we're gonna provide an
additional Patriot air decision air
defense battery
this is crazy but there's actually a
reason for it people are getting very
rich from this people are getting very
rich from this that's why Washington
supports it and very soon we're going to
give you a case study on who exactly is
getting rich from it so when people who
are promoting this war that is killing
an endless number of ukrainians are
personally benefiting from it and you
should know that but the cost to us is
profound in fact we're sending so much
military equipment to Ukraine to
zielinski and his wife that we're
running out of weapons for our own
military to defend our own country and
that's not a guess the secretary of the
Navy Carlos Del Toro just said that out
loud quote with regards to deliveries of
weapon systems for the fight in Ukraine
yeah that's always a concern for us if
the conflict does go on for another six
months or another year it certainly
continues to stress the supply chain in
ways that are challenging
in other words you can either defend
Ukraine's Borders or you can defend the
United States of America
which is it
well most members of Congress are
choosing Ukraine which tells you
everything but a small number coming to
their senses in the house Thomas Massey
of Kentucky is one of them
we've spent more in Ukraine the U.S
Congress has then we spend on all of our
roads and bridges in an entire year the
entire infrastructure of this country
the roads and bridges the real
infrastructure we don't spend as much on
that here as we've spent on Ukraine in
nine months
I think that's despicable our priorities
are all out of whack and I'll finish
with this we're trying to get the
documents here to find out where the
money went what we really need is a full
audit
so this is a crime against our country
being perpetrated by the Democratic
party with the full buy-in of most
Republicans but a few have dissented JD
Vance just started in the U.S Senate
representing state of Ohio subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight